upper left-hand corner and I'm going to
put positive two now this is important
to recognize if we were dividing by X
plus two we'd be using negative 2 here
so it's going to be the opposite sign
okay and then what we're gonna do is
we're going to write the coefficients of
this polynomial so 3 negative 2 5 0 8 ok
now wait a second why is zero well see
how this is going in descending order 4
3 2 1 0
right so the degrees of the terms are
going in descending order if we skip
over any of the terms we have to put a
zero as a placeholder so if I was
missing 5 x squared or this x squared
term I would have a 0 here and a 0 here
and then the constant so you want to go
from the highest degree down to the
lowest degree and you want to go an
order and if you're missing any of those
terms just put zero as a placeholder
okay then what I do is I just draw a
line like so and what you want to do
this is the first step sometimes
students forget this you want to drop
down that first term so whatever this
number is just bring it right down like
that okay now what you're going to do is
you're going to multiply on the diagonal
okay and you're going to put the result
of that product okay right here so this
is going to be 2 times 3 which is 6 then
you're gonna add straight down okay
which gives us 4 and then you're going
to multiply in the diagonal okay so 2
times 4 which is 8 and you're gonna add
straight down then you're going to
multiply in the diagonal 2 times 13
which is 26 you're gonna add straight
down and then you're going to multiply
on the diagonal and you're going to add
straight down
which gives you 60 this is the remainder
so now what we're going to do since we
were dividing by X minus 2 this is 3 X
to the fourth this goes down always by
one degree so if you started with X to
the fourth now this is going to be X
cubed so what we have is 3x cubed plus
4x squared plus 13x plus 26 plus the
remainder 60 over the divisor what
you're dividing by so that's your
quotient that's your answer
you just have to remember if there's a
remainder here just put the remainder
over what you're dividing